- Hi, everyone, welcome to
the Homeroom livestream.
Sal here from Khan Academy.
Super-excited about the conversation
we're going to have today.
But before we get started,
I will give my standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder
that we are not for profit
and we can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate
and make a donation of any level.
It all makes a huge difference.
We've been running at a deficit pre-COVID,
and that deficit has only grown
as we've gone through this crisis.
And with that in mind, I'd like
to give a special shout-out
to several organizations
that have stepped up
to help us close our gap.
A special thanks to Bank
of America, google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, Novartis,
and the Amgen Foundation,
and many others who have
supported Khan Academy
through the years, to allow
us to be in a position
to help folks, teachers, parents, students
through the COVID crisis,
but we do need more help.
So anything you can do, much appreciated.
So with that, I'm super-excited
to introduce our guest today.
There's a lot to talk about.
We have Lily Eskelsen Garcia,
President of the National
Education Association,
the largest teacher's union
in the country, is that right?
Or one of the largest. (laughs)
Thanks so much for joining us, Lily.
- It's an honor, thank you for having me.
- So maybe a good place to start,
obviously all the
conversation, and this isn't,
normally this is, you know,
we have these education conversations,
but this has turned into
a national conversation
or international conversation
about the state of school closures
or school openings and safety.
Just where's your mind right now?
Where are we in the process?
How are y'all thinking about it?
What are y'all advocating for?
What do you see is actually happening
and how is it going to play out
over the next few weeks or months?
- Well, Sal, it's really
why I was so excited
to be on the show, because
there's so much misinformation
out there about it seems like everything.
So first I wanna say there is no one,
probably other than their parents,
who want those kids
back in-person learning
more than their teachers,
and all of the counselors
and the school nurse and everybody,
we want our kids back.
But we wanna go back
in that school building
when and where we can do
it without someone dying.
You know, that I even
have to say that out loud
is a little weird, but I
noticed when I was subtle
and I'd say without someone getting sick,
bottom line is it's a
global pandemic out there.
There's something in
the air swirling around
that's killing people, right?
Thousands and thousands of people
have their lungs attacked.
It's impossible for them to breathe.
It's a horrible way to die.
And we don't seem to all be getting that.
Medical professionals have told us
that the most dangerous place
to be in this global pandemic
is in a closed, poorly ventilated building
with lots of people crowding together,
breathing on each other hour
after hour, day after day,
which is the description
of my sixth grade classroom
the year I had 39 kids.
So I worried on any given
day that if someone coughed
in the back of the room, I
was gonna catch their cold.
I knew it, three times a year,
I was gonna get somebody's cold.
This is not that.
This is quite different.
This means somebody coughs
and I end up in the ICU.
Somebody coughs on their best friend
and this kid is infected and asymptomatic,
and goes home and hugs his babysitter.
Who's his babysitter?
Grandma.
And we know now with some,
there's new information
coming out all the time,
this is still so new, but
that we have people who say,
kids can't get sick, kids are immune.
The President, governors,
the Secretary of Education,
lots of people giving
really bad information.
We now know that not
only can kids get sick,
not only can kids end up in the hospital,
but a disproportionate amount
of those kids who are ill
are minority children.
They're black and brown children,
they're from immigrant communities.
They are at greater risk.
And so they're also in the schools
with the oldest buildings,
with the poorest ventilation,
the most overcrowded classrooms.
We have to understand that
this is dangerous to children
and it is dangerous to their families,
and it is dangerous to their teachers.
And I am an excellent, very,
very good sixth grade teacher.
You would want your kid in my sixth grade.
I'm not an infectious
disease medical professional.
So when I need to know
something about that,
I hear what Dr. Fauci is saying
or public health professionals.
They're not saying anything different.
They are all together,
the scientific community.
The only thing we can do right now
is try not to infect each other.
'Cause if we do, people die.
So they're saying you
don't even think about
opening a school, a restaurant, a movie.
You don't go to a rally
until you've got this
infection rate under control.
It's now skyrocketing.
It's exploding in more and more places
instead of fewer and fewer places.
And so we're really worried
about these one-size-fits-all,
open up the schools,
stuff those kids back in.
Why?
We need to get our jobs numbers up,
we need their parents
back, it's gonna backfire.
It's gonna backfire and they will be doing
what they're already doing
in those premature openings.
Kids are getting sick.
They're infecting the
community, everybody.
And now they're having
to close the schools.
The chaos, the insecurity that
families are going through.
It's a crisis, let's
treat it like a crisis.
Listen to the people who know
what they're talking about.
- You know, that makes a ton of sense.
And to your point, a lot of it,
it's amazing that we have to articulate it
because it makes so much sense.
How do you think this plays out?
And then you mentioned kind
of this one-size-fits-all,
everyone open schools by, no matter what,
doesn't make sense,
especially where we are
in the pandemic and in the incidence rate.
And some of these early
cases that we're seeing,
the school season hasn't even,
the school year hasn't even started yet,
or it's very early
stages in several places,
but we're already seeing these cases.
As soon as they opened up,
within three or four days,
200 students, 800 students, whatever,
people are testing positive.
I guess there's two questions.
One is, are there not
one-size-fits-all solutions
that could get us a
little bit closer to this,
whether it's hybrid.
Could we use outdoor learning?
I know during the tuberculosis
crisis last century,
they did a lot of outdoor schooling.
Are there things that we can do?
Or are there incident rates
in certain communities
at which point, the
epidemiologists are telling you
that, yeah, that rate
and maybe if you take
the right precautions
and maybe if you use outdoor
well, it might be okay.
What are you seeing there?
- So I'm seeing some of
the most creative educators
in the world who are really trying to say,
all right, so distance,
how are we gonna distance?
Disinfect, we're not talking
about a little Windex.
We're talking about disinfecting
using some pretty specific things.
And by the way, little kids, I love 'em.
I loved those 39 kids.
They are little germ factories, all right?
So they are touching their noses
and they're touching their
little grubby mitts everywhere.
So it's especially important
that we have a protocol on disinfecting.
Do we have the masks?
And do we have the ability
to do some serious screening
as kids come into the building where,
do they have a cough, a temperature?
Are we doing any kind of
even group and random COVID testing?
So all of the above are what
the disease professionals
are saying we have to do, but
here's the important thing.
And I've seen some of the most creative,
here's how we're gonna
distance those kindergarteners.
How are you gonna keep,
hula hoops, really?
Yes, that's one of my members, she said,
we are using creative use of space.
Instead of having 20 kindergartners,
we're putting like eight to 10 in a room.
We took out all the desks
and we put hula hoops
and pillows on the floor,
and that's their space.
And they don't go out of
their hula hoop space.
They're not gonna wear the mask.
Little kids, that's a toy.
So they're wearing space helmets.
They're going to the moon.
And they've got the plexiglass helmets.
They're doing what they
can with what they have,
which isn't a lot.
But here's what I want people to know.
Folks keep forgetting
the most important part.
The number of the infection
rate in your community
is going to be the infection rate
of the people walking into that building.
The teacher lives in the neighborhood,
those kids and their families
live in those neighborhoods.
That school is a reflection
of what's going on in
the broader community.
And so if you have, like
they had in New Orleans,
a 20 or 25% infection rate,
you can probably bet that 25%
of the big and little people
that walk into that school
are going to be infected by COVID.
Only this time you're putting
them in these classrooms
that have poor ventilation
that, even with your hula hoops,
they're gonna be passing
each other in the hall.
That's why the first thing,
and it's the thing most people say,
yeah, well, we don't
really care about that.
Care about the community infection rate
until you get it down to about
5% where it's manageable,
where you can say maybe 5% of the folks
coming into this school,
and we can screen for them.
We can screen and do some
health checks for them.
But that's the most important part
and it's the part that's out of our hands.
All the hula hoops and
face masks in the world
will not help a surging virus rate.
And so that's what we're worried about,
it's that folks are looking at this list,
infection rates, masks,
disinfectant, distancing.
And there's people who don't
really know what they're doing
saying, well, let's do the
masks and the plexiglass,
but we don't know how
to distance the kids.
And yeah, we've got a 3% infection rate,
we can't do anything about it.
So let's just pick and
choose what might be easiest,
most convenient, least expensive.
It doesn't work that way.
This is complicated, it's hard.
And it's expensive if
you're gonna do it right.
I was alarmed when I
heard the President say,
well, I looked at the guidance,
that costs a lot of money,
and I told 'em to go back and rewrite it.
That's not how it works, don't do that.
Listen to the people who
are trying to save our lives
and why wouldn't we listen to them?
So, number one, I'm a little
mad, okay, I'm very angry
at a lot of politicians,
local, state, and national,
who told folks, we don't
have to have a plan.
It'll go away, it's magic.
Nope, it's science, it's really science.
And what they didn't do
in January and February
is the result, is that
we've prolonged this.
We are the outlier in the
United States of America.
There are countries who
do not have infection,
got it very early.
And now I'm getting in questions like,
what are you going to do, teachers,
to make sure we can still keep them safe?
What's your plan B?
- Yeah.
- I don't have one.
- And what you're describing is complete--
- And it's not a fair
question to ask a teacher,
what about the politicians?
- And what you're describing
makes all the sense in the world.
You know, we had Randi
Weingarten, your peer,
at the National Federation of Teachers
saying essentially the same things.
You know, you have to
take basic precautions,
do contact tracing, and
then get your infection rate
in a community down to a certain
threshold, at which point,
your point you're making
and Randi Weingarten made
is that like, it's not
that people are saying
it has to be risk-free.
Obviously, even in pre-COVID,
there's all sorts of risks
in our life.
But it just has to
become a reasonable risk.
And it's not just about
teachers or students.
This is about the community.
This is just epidemiologically sound,
I have trouble saying that
word, for the entire community.
So we actually had Dr.
Fauci on the same livestream
and the best that I could understand
when I asked him the questions
of how this is all going to play out,
it really feels like the
most optimistic scenario
is one of these vaccines that
are currently in phase three,
which we've already started manufacturing
essentially speculatively,
that they might, hopefully,
prove effective in the
December/January timeframe.
At which point we have this
massive logistical challenge
of distributing hundreds of
millions of doses of vaccine.
And we don't know to
what degree they'll work
or how many people take it.
Simultaneously, you have
the therapeutic lens where,
hopefully, some therapies will come out
in the January/February timeframe
where COVID can be less
deadly, less severe.
Hopefully, we get to some of those things.
But any way you look at it,
everyone I've talked to,
we had the CEO of Novartis
on this livestream as well.
They're all saying it's kind of a year
that we're in this world
that you've just described.
And so how are you thinking about it?
How do you think educators
should think about
what looks like it could be
at least a full school year
of some form of distance learning?
- First of all, we were so thrilled
that the House of Representatives,
and who says they're ever
thrilled with anything
that Congress does, but
we were actually thrilled
that they listened to us.
And they said, yes, you
prepare for the face masks
and the disinfectant, and yes,
we need all of these things.
And please don't make us have to lay off
the school nurse, all right?
So we got a chunk of money from
the House of Representatives
that is languishing now
with Mitch McConnell
not wanting to bring it to a vote.
But one of the things we said was,
and you do have to have simultaneously
the ability for a school district
to deliver distance learning.
And so we asked for all kinds of funding
for a family to be able to
bring Wi-Fi into their home.
That's like indoor plumbing now, you know?
And guess what, not
everybody's mom has a laptop
and has an extra tablet
sitting around the house.
We kinda take that for granted
that, well, everyone has.
No, stop thinking everyone
has just 'cause you have it.
And so there's some
extra money, $4 billion
that would help with the technology
that could deliver distance learning,
especially to the neediest families
who are least likely to
be able to afford things
like an extra tablet
and Wi-Fi in their home.
When we ran out of those school buildings,
120,000 school buildings back in March,
like someone pulled the fire alarm
and all simultaneously 120,000
school buildings emptied out,
it wasn't for the fun of it.
It was because infectious
disease, medical experts said
this is a pandemic.
It is growing.
We have to do something to
stop infecting each other.
And a school is like the worst place
to do something like that.
So we left.
And within a day, we had
people who were not trained
in delivering virtual
classes saying, all right,
what's this thing called Zoom?
What are we doin' here?
And they were going online
and they were getting information,
and they were connecting with each other.
My organization, we were just
bombarded with people saying,
what you got, I gotta do this tomorrow.
And I've got third graders,
or I've got a calculus class,
or I've got special ed students,
or I've got kids that don't speak English,
and I've got to deliver
instruction and sometimes services,
and sometimes lunch to these kids.
'Cause that's what a school
is, it's a community.
And it does take a village to
deliver what those kids need.
Sometimes that school nurse
is that family's primary care physician,
because they can't afford
to go to the doctor.
So we took all of that,
we pulled it together.
Oh, my Lord, it wasn't perfect.
It was frustrating,
it's still frustrating.
But we knew in May, people were saying,
this is going in the wrong direction.
This is not gonna be,
okay, now they told us
the warm weather would clear it all.
Nope, didn't clear it all up.
And in fact, they opened up some places
that they shouldn't have.
And folks rushed into the bar
and they should've known better.
And they ended up getting
sick, getting other people sick
who went to work, who sat on
a bus, who did what people do.
And all of a sudden things are
spiking all over the country.
So it became very, very clear to teachers,
to school boards and even to governors,
okay, this is not going away.
What are we gonna do
in August and September
as schools start to reopen?
And that's when we, it was in May,
we went to the House and said,
you've gotta give us some
money for technology,
for home technology, for
kids that don't have access,
don't have opportunity.
We were delivering to some of these kids
paper packets of worksheets.
I hate worksheets, but
it was all we could do.
The only technology in some
homes was mom's telephone
and she took it to work with her
'cause she had a service job
stacking grocery shelves or something.
And we couldn't even call on the telephone
our students and find
out how they were doing
or give them some instruction.
And we're still just appalled that in May,
we thought we were on a
fast track to getting this,
and it's still sitting in the Senate.
So abandon all hope something
coming from the Senate
that's gonna get to these kids in time.
Schools are already opening
and they didn't do it right.
And those schools, many of
them, are already closing.
And it's causing chaos in families
when we could have had
a plan, we could have,
it didn't have to be like this.
But now we're still trying to figure out.
Now in some places, in Nebraska,
one of my colleagues called
and said, we know which of
our kids didn't have Wi-Fi.
We just lost them.
So now we're working with
local television stations.
We're just talking about
you've got a $10 antenna
on your old-fashioned
TV, it's not even cable.
But some of the TV stations
are giving us an hour
where we could say, this
is for younger grades,
this is for middle school,
this is for high school.
And we're doing some general
project-based learning
so at least there's something.
At least there's something,
and the parents can tune
into a television program.
We're doing whatever it takes.
We wish that some of the lawmakers,
the people that have the purse strings,
we wish that they would step up
and see that they could be helping us
instead of being the obstacle
for getting something very important done.
- And what would you think
would be kind of the order,
let's hope, and I agree with you 100%,
in a world where we're
doing a trillion here
and a trillion there of stimulus packages,
the Internet connectivity issue
is a small pittance there.
But let's hope that we're
able to get the devices
and get the Internet access
for a lot of these students.
And I know that a lot of school districts
have been doing some heroic things,
distributing tens or hundreds
of thousands of devices.
Even then we've been hearing about
there's some subset of kids
that just don't have
enough supports at home,
maybe not ideal environments,
you know, 5%, 10% of kids
that even if they're getting the access,
they're just getting disengaged.
So if we had more resources,
where would it go?
Would it go towards, you
know, there's a question here
from Janet Martin Rodriguez on Facebook,
are teachers getting
enough support and training
they need to keep students
engaged, even excited?
So teacher training is one element.
There is, more social
supports is another element.
I don't know how you deliver
that in a world of COVID.
Then there's obviously
online tools and instruction,
obviously what we do at Khan
Academy, and other tools.
Where do you see, you know,
if you had a blank check
and I know that's a little
bit of daydreaming right now,
but I would love, you know,
I think there might be
an openness, hopefully,
at some point when people
realize how serious this is,
what would be the order of operations?
- And I'm never going to
be one of the Pollyanna,
let's make lemonade out of this.
This is horrible and people are dying.
And I'm not gonna say,
oh, but the good news.
There's no, there's no good news here.
But let me tell you the
urgency that it has produced
is how important that
basic teacher training.
And I know I'm talking about,
you said like a magic wand
or a blank check, and I'm
saying what if we could go
in a time machine to the future,
I know that this is the long
game, this is the long-term.
But we need it, we need how to engage
with teaching on technology,
distance learning,
what that looks like if
you're an art teacher,
if you're a calculus teacher,
if you're a third grade teacher.
I'm a sixth grade teacher
and I know that you will
be impressed to learn
that I have a Master's degree
in instructional technology,
which I got on an Atari 800 in 1983.
So yeah, I need to like up
my game just a tiny bit.
I can do Oregon Trail
like nobody's business.
But I'm thinking that maybe,
maybe I could upgrade.
Most of us, unless you
were in a special program
that did distance learning
for kids in rural areas,
we do have some educators
who their specialty is distance learning.
Now we have to look at this like
technology is your blackboard,
technology is the chalk you use.
It's how you have to deliver.
This isn't gonna be the
first time and the last time
that we have some kind of emergency
where kids, where they can't
walk into that school building.
We've done things with snow days
and there's a hurricane or a tornado.
I mean, we've had these horrible crises
where the school got blown away.
Look at how long Katrina
took to recover from.
And there was no plan B for these kids.
So now maybe our eyes are open
that becoming a teacher means
you know about your subject,
you know how to teach that subject,
and those are two different
things, by the way,
and you know all the tools
that you may have to use
to teach that subject.
And technology is going to
be more and more important
that we become comfortable with it.
And that we understand how important it is
to have that technology in a child's home
so that they can do their homework,
not just in case of a global pandemic.
But we've always known
that the homework gap
mimics the technology gap
in that child's living space
in that child's home.
And that there are kids
who have wonderful tools,
they have access.
I wouldn't take anything
away from anybody.
But it was important for those kids,
and their parents were able to afford it
and saying, yep, this is
really, really important
for my kid to succeed.
They're right.
It's important for all
kids to have that access
and that opportunity.
And just like we would
say in the school building
for those kids, we
fight for a kid's access
to a school nurse, a librarian,
a counselor, the arts,
the broad range of programs
that every child needs.
And now they're all gonna need access
not just to the equipment,
that's actually the easy part,
but access to a professional
who knows what she or he is doing
to make sure that those kids
who are learning that way
are being taught well.
It's not my favorite way to teach.
It really isn't.
I love to hug kids, I can't do that now.
And I don't want them to fall behind.
And I want them to be safe.
So if I'm a true
professional, I have to say,
all right, on a dime,
I know how to best use this technology.
I know the do's and don'ts,
and I know what my audience,
what my students need from me.
And sometimes they need a hug
and sometimes they need me
to know how to engage them
on a screen that they're looking at.
I want those skills.
- And what do you think
that could look like?
Obviously, we can't
paint the full picture,
but sketch what it looks like.
'Cause I think to your point,
everyone's been talking about
just the social distancing,
and do we open or close.
And then the next level
they've been talking about device access.
But there hasn't been
a lot of conversation
about just what does at least adequate,
we don't even have to talk about great,
but what does an adequate
experience look like
in this world?
If you could sketch, what
would be your expectations
for your own children or if
you were in the classroom
teaching a sixth grade classroom,
how would you run your
classroom in math or English
or social sciences right now?
- Well, one of the things that
we know is a great advantage
to our students is to have mom or dad
or a big brother or sister helping them,
especially if you're
dealing with younger kids.
But I think it's the
same with older kids too,
where they don't plug
in or they don't engage.
And part of it may be that we
need to know how to develop
better pacing and better lesson plans,
and things that are meant to
be engaging on that screen.
Right now for a lot of our
teachers, it was all right,
we've got a free Zoom or
we've got a free something,
and now go do whatever you were doing
with your 35 kids yesterday,
and now just do the same thing
looking at them sitting
in 35 different kitchens
on their tablets and laptops.
And we know that that's
not the best pedagogy.
We know that you have to engage kids
and you have to ask them questions,
and they have to be able to ask questions
and interact with each other.
And there's ways that we can do that.
NEA is actually giving
some webinars for teachers
that have never taught
online that are saying,
I just need a, I need a primer on this.
I don't know the first thing
about what this format can do,
or my district is using
this kind of a platform,
and I don't know what a platform is.
So, I mean, we're talking about
strict, strict, strict beginners
and doing some webinars.
Anybody that wants to find out more about
what NEA is just putting out there free,
it's nea.org/covidaction.
Because these are the actions
that many of our members,
thousands and thousands have said,
if you can do anything for me,
just help me know what the options are.
Because I don't wanna
just look at a screen
and recite from a textbook.
I know what I'm doing
when I'm with those kids.
How do I get to something
that looks like that online?
And so, again, I'm not an expert in that,
but we're putting some of the teachers
that have done this before.
And we wanna look at
what you're doing, Sal,
with your online experience.
Because people are desperate to say,
if I don't know what I'm supposed
to know, I gotta learn it
and I got a short time
to really ramp this up.
Because we don't want to
close teaching and learning.
I've had too many reporters who've said,
are you for closing the
schools, are you going to?
And the whole thing, it's
like, this is the building.
And yeah, we don't want
the building to be unsafe,
unhealthy, we don't
wanna rush into a place
that they told us to rush out
of because it wasn't safe.
So let's get that part right.
But we don't wanna close
teaching and learning.
Those kids need us.
They need us to deliver instruction,
they need us to deliver services.
They need us to deliver lunch.
So we're trying to develop our own plan
as a learning community,
sometimes school by school
or district by district.
And along with all of
those practical things,
I wanna know how to use
this so that my kids
get all I can give them.
And for us it's not like,
another reporter said,
are you scared that now that
everyone knows how easy it is
to teach online and that parents are just,
they know how easy it is to
just turn on their computer?
And I went, you know, talk
to some of those parents.
'Cause they're the ones
that are begging the schools
to please open up.
It's not easy.
It's hard to be a teacher.
It's hard to do this right.
We love our work.
We're professionals at it.
We put a lot of sweat equity into it.
It's a labor of love for us.
And it is for those parents as well.
We wanna get it right and
that's what we're committed to.
And I don't have a magic wand
and it's gonna look very, very
different in every community.
And by the way, there
are some communities,
this is the most creative
one that's online learning
that I've heard of, and it's in Maryland.
It's a state, the state of Maryland.
They have a plan, whoa.
So they're the outlier.
But their plan was, look,
we probably could open this building.
It's super-disinfected with all the masks
and the health screenings,
but we can put a small
fraction of the kids in here
and socially distance.
So they said, so let's go with that.
We're going to do distance learning.
We are going to have a
plan for distance learning
so that it's not just, you know,
we're closing the school
tomorrow, go do distance learning.
Everyone has planned for this.
We're gonna plan on how we're
gonna deliver those lunches
and those homework packets.
We're gonna use the
buses in a reverse way.
They're going to be delivering
things to the kids' homes,
not picking up the kids
to go to the school.
And so all hands on deck,
they're all doing it.
But they said there are some kids
who might not have mom and dad at home.
We can hand 'em a laptop.
We might even be able to set
up some kind of Wi-Fi broadband
in a parking lot somewhere,
but mom and dad aren't there
to bring the kids to download
something in a parking lot.
They're not there to explain
to a second or third grader
what it is that we're doing.
So they're going to open up
their schools to those kids
who need the most, who don't
have it in their homes.
And they're not giving in-person
instruction to those kids.
Those kids are opening up the
school laptop and tablets.
There's adult supervision,
but the teacher is online,
and it's some of the
paraprofessionals who were saying,
all right, I can help you.
Like your mom or dad would be
helping you if they had a job
where they were working from
home or had access to that.
And for those teachers
that are teaching special education kids,
especially the medically
fragile kids who need so much
and they're in a very specific atmosphere.
They're saying we're
gonna bring those kids in.
There are very few of
them, we can distance,
we can disinfect, and we're
not opening the school.
♪ Ta da ♪
But we're making sure
that everybody has access
to what the most fortunate
kids have access to.
So I'm so proud of educators.
And there are lots of school boards
that are listening to us,
as they say, all right,
Dr. Fauci says that it's not
ready to open this school.
We still want teaching
and learning going on.
You're the professionals, tell
us how we can do this safely
and do it competently.
And it's happening in more
places than you think.
What makes the news is we did it wrong.
We opened the school,
hundreds of kids got sick.
Front page news.
And it is a cautionary tale,
it should be front page news.
But those places that have quietly done it
the way they were supposed to,
they listened to medical experts,
they listened to education experts.
They said, parents, well,
what can you do in your homes?
What can't you do in your homes?
Those are the places that
are quietly showing us
the way forward.
And maybe we can give
a little more attention
to the, not just the cautionary tales,
but the success stories.
- No, I love that.
The example you gave of Maryland,
actually I hadn't heard of it
and I hadn't heard of that model,
but it makes a ton of sense.
And I'm going add that to my
talk track of ideas for folks.
I also giggled a little bit,
'cause I also get the question
that you, I guess, got around
will distance learning replace
teachers and all of that.
And I almost laugh every time I hear that.
'Cause I'm sometimes a
bit of a poster child
for online learning or whatever else
and I'm the first one to say,
if I had to pick between a
live teacher and technology,
I would pick the live
teacher any day for my kids
or anyone else's kids.
And pure distance learning
is not a good solution
for the great majority of students.
What we should be thinking about is
how do we get all of the
power of an amazing teacher,
especially ideally once
we're post-pandemic,
in person so that you have
that, you're sharing a room,
you can have that hug,
you can have that human
to human connection.
And then think about how
tools can be in service,
once again, not technology
for technology's sake,
but technology and service
to true pedagogical
or social, emotional goals.
So it couldn't be more aligned.
And you know I'd love to go offline
and talk about how we can help.
'Cause I think we're very aligned on this.
And just in the remaining time
we have, what do you think,
everything we're describing,
this is clearly a suboptimal year.
Not everyone's going to be
able to do what Maryland's did.
There's gonna be kids that
are gonna fall further behind,
not be supported.
It's probably, this year's
probably gonna drive
more inequity, not less.
What do you think's gonna
be the outcome of it?
If we're talking about, if
we're having this conversation
in five years and we say,
yeah, COVID changed a lot,
and this is what the outcome
of it was, positive, negative.
I'd love to, you know, put
your prognostication hat,
what are we gonna be
looking at permanently
in the education system or
in society because of this?
- I really appreciate the
gravity of that question.
And I don't think we ask it enough.
We're gonna look back on this year
as a lost year for so many kids
because of the political lack
of will to take this seriously
and to do what needed to be done.
The magical thinking of too
many key political figures,
local, state and national,
has devastated lives.
And not just the people who
lost someone, lost their health
or their life to COVID,
but these schoolchildren.
I just keep saying this
because you can't see it
because I turned my
computer away from the wall
that I have punched several holes in.
Just so upset and so
angry at the poor judgment
of the magical thinking of politicians
who got really, really good advice.
I'm a sixth grade teacher.
I understood that advice.
I understood, I'm not a scientist,
but anybody could explain
or listen to the explanation
and say, well, yeah, that makes sense.
And these politicians
that could have done something about it,
I hate to just dwell on that.
But these kids have been
sacrificed to the bad judgment
of too many politicians.
And I want to make it my life's mission
to try and recapture some
of their loss this year.
And it's gonna be a really tough job.
What we should be doing going forward
I think with new and better decisions
will be what are we going
to go back and take,
especially those kids that had access
and opportunity to nothing, if anything.
I'm not even just talking about,
well, look at all the folks
that didn't get to go to
their graduation party.
Yeah, that's really sad.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about someone,
you only get one year
to be a first grader.
You only get one year
to put the consonants
and the vowels together
and have it click and go
I get it, this is called
reading, oh, my Lord.
And to have fun so that you make reading
something that you just
do because you love it.
For some of these kids,
we're gonna have to go back
and give them something
extra and give them something
not just remedial but
something where we say
you're the kids that
we're not going to put
in an overcrowded classroom
and expect to get caught up.
You're the kids that we are
going to prioritize the tools
and the techniques and the programs
that we're gonna be doing with you
that are going to incorporate the arts
and sports and field trips.
We are going to do something to bring joy
into your learning
experience that was lost
because of this lost year.
Funding for public schools has
been miserable for so long.
And I reject people who, well-meaningly,
they will think they're saying
something real and they say,
schools are the fundamental
foundation of our economy.
It's our best investment.
All right, so yes.
And for me that's like four on the list.
It's a human and civil
right to an education.
I don't care if that choir
puts one dime into the economy.
It was that child's right
to have that experience.
It is the foundation of our democracy
of being a good citizen,
of being a good neighbor,
being a good parent, a good human being.
So there's so much wrapped
up in that public school,
I'm gonna start crying.
We forget that.
And we think of it as a
transactional piece of the economy.
It's so much bigger than that.
And we have got, we owe,
we owe this lost year
to millions of kids,
and we should make that
a national priority.
- Well, no, I couldn't
agree with you more, Lily.
And I'm saying this completely genuinely,
view Khan Academy as in service to you
and all of the teachers
that you're representing.
We view ourselves that way,
and especially in this crisis,
we wanna do whatever we can
to mitigate the suboptimality
of what we're all facing this coming year,
and to help mitigate and
close whatever gaps we can
in the aftermath of
whatever all of this is.
But really appreciate the conversation.
I learned a ton, and I hope that this is
the start of our conversations together.
- Absolutely, thank you
so much for having me.
- Thanks so much, Lily.
Well, thank you all for
joining what I, again,
a fascinating conversation.
The whole world is going through
a very tough set of
circumstances right now,
but I think the school issue
and the ability to make sure
that inequity doesn't grow
as we go through school closures,
or physical school
closures, as Lily mentioned,
we're gonna hopefully
continue to educate kids
in any ways we can.
I think it's the issue
of our day, you know,
that and the economics.
And the education one, in a lot of ways,
might be more important
even than the economic,
'cause it has very
long-lasting implications.
So thanks so much for
joining this conversation
and I look forward to
seeing y'all later this week
for more of this Homeroom livestream.
Thanks, everyone.